speaking of uh the Tyranny daily wire
has this report shortly after taking
office on January 2021 President Joe
Biden's Administration pressured
Facebook to stifle the daily wires reach
on the platform and boost the reach of
Legacy Media Outlets according to
meeting notes recently turned over to
Congress
the newly released documents which were
reviewed by the daily wire show that
Facebook repeatedly confirmed to the
White House that it was working to
re-engineer its platform in order to
accomplish the administration's
directives on suppressing content that
clashed with its coveted vaccine agenda
the meeting notes first reported by just
the news detailed discussions then White
House digital director Rob Flaherty had
with Facebook Executives in 2021 where
the Biden staffer pressured the big tech
company to moderate content related to
cover vaccines in order to enforce the
administration's policy goals
during one meeting on April 14 2021
Flaherty asked Facebook about changing
the algorithm to push content from The
New York Times And The Wall Street
Journal over news from the daily wire
and other polarizing entities
quote if you were to change the
algorithm so that people were more
likely to see New York Times Wall Street
Journal any authoritative news source
over daily wire Tomi lahren polarizing
people
you wouldn't have a mechanism to check
the material impact he asked
um
at the time of the meeting in April 2021
and in the months following the daily
wire was the leading publisher on
Facebook getting more far more clicks
and reactions than the New York Times
Wall Street Journal and every other
conservative liberal news site
the meeting notes show the bite
Administration telling Facebook that it
was concerned about misinformation on
the platform that caused many Americans
to be hesitant about rolling up their
sleeves and getting vaccinated now it's
funny because
you still sometimes hear from some
conservative critics of ours of the
daily wire
that the daily wire somehow part of the
establishment right or whatever you
still see this
and uh one of the establishment we're
establishment chills over here at the
daily work meanwhile there are meetings
at the White House about how to reduce
our reach okay we have the White House
conspiring against us YouTube is
demonetizing US Fox News has blacklisted
us we have fact Checkers quote unquote
and media Watchdog quote unquote leftist
activities activist groups working
around the clock
to put out hit pieces scare away
advertisers try to bankrupt us on and on
and on we are to put it mildly
not a part of this club okay we don't
want to be in it and we certainly aren't
invited uh they hate us and they hate us
more than they hate most other outlets
and people on the right
that's undeniable it just is
and there's a reason you know
I see all this as affirmation well if
you want some positive news in the
culture works since Roe v Wade was
overturned the left has lost their minds
making abortion their official Sacrament
the pro-life efforts which are now more
important than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
pro-lifers did not go away they
increased in number in fact as one of
the largest pro-life organizations in
the world no one is in a better position
than 40 days of life to end abortion in
each state in a post-rural America 40
Days for life is changing hearts and
Minds in the most blue pro-abortion
States out there they have a record
number of locations since Roe was
overturned and they grew in both
volunteers and locations with about 1
million Volunteers in 1500 cities they
hold peaceful vigils outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal Battles by protecting free
speech for their volunteers by giving a
tax deductible gift of any amount at
40daysforlife.com that's
40daysforlife.com
as many of you know we have been giving
our dog rough greens for a while now and
and we love it our dog has a ton more
energy is always running around with our
kids I'm serious our dog and our kids
constantly have the Zoomies
what they're always running around in
love playing fetch in the backyard Dr
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America literally did I
know before I got rough grains dog food
is dead food everyone knows nutrition
isn't Brown it's green
let rough grains boost your dog's food
back to life rough grains is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins that you need if you
want to have the Zoomies plus minerals
probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antiatics anti antioxidants that your
dog needs I know when I eat that stuff I
have the Zoomies all day long you don't
have to go out and buy new dog food not
that I'm eating dog food whatever you
just sprinkle rough grains on their food
every day dog owners everywhere are
raving about rough greens it supports
healthy joints improves bad breath
boosts energy levels and so much more we
are what we eat and that goes for dogs
too Dr Dennis black is so confident
rough greens will improve your dog's
health he's offering my listeners a free
jump start trial bag so your dog can try
at a free jump start trial bag you'll be
at your door in just a few business days
go to freeruffgreens.com Walsh or call
844 rough 700 that's free ruffgreens.com
Walsh or call 844 rough 700 today
we hear so much about affirmation these
days it's important to be affirmed well
this this is affirmation for me I'm not
happy about it
I mean the plan to reduce our reach on
Facebook for example was successful and
uh very successful and we've taken a
major major
Financial hit because of it I can tell
you that
so I'm not happy about it I prefer that
it wasn't happening but I know that it
is happening because they fear us and
they fear us because we're effective you
know if you let us on a Level Playing
Field if you let us simply have access
to the audience to our own audience
like if you let us people come to us and
say Hey I want more of this content I'm
a fan of this I want to and then you let
us just access that audience nothing
special we don't need any spec we don't
need you to prop us up in any special
way just let us have access to our
audience that's it
and let the chips fall where they may
and if nobody's interested in and we're
irrelevant then then fine then we'll all
go to business and we're gonna have to
find other other jobs that could happen
too but
um
we know that if you do that
we dominate you know we win the argument
we uh we were the top publisher on
Facebook for a reason we can win hearts
and Minds
that's what we were doing we are doing
their only recourse is to stifle and
silence us it's all they have that's all
they have
but even that's not working
because that's the thing that we also
decide is that we're not going to let
these
bastards chase us away to some
irrelevant corner of the internet to
some internet ghetto
we're gonna stay right in the thick of
it and we're gonna fight this out and
that's what we're doing
and uh and you know deck is stacked
against us in a big way on a lot of
these platforms but uh that's what we
decided to do or continue to do it
and this to me is just more confirmation
that um
that it's important fight to have
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there